protected and they can Bank as normal
customers should not notice any changes
whilst The Wider UK banking system
remains safe sound and well capitalized
using stabilization powers granted by
the Banking Act 2009 which afforded us
the stability to safely manage the
failure of banks we have for stalled
disruption in the tech sector and
supported confidence in the UK Financial
system the resolution action action was
taken by the bank of England in
consultation with hm treasury using its
powers to transfer the UK business of
SVP to a private sector purchaser
as required by the act the bank of
England consulted the treasury the
Prudential regulation Authority and the
financial conduct Authority on its
assessment that all required conditions
for this transaction had been met
we've been able to achieve this outcome
the best possible outcome in short order
without any taxpayer money or government
guarantees
there has been no bailout and the
actions taken are a win for customers
taxpayers and the banking system
the transfer of svb UK to a buyer has
allowed the treasury to limit the risk
to public funds by ensuring that
shareholders and creditors rather than
depositors bear losses to help achieve
this result the bank of England has made
a related instrument bringing about a
mandatory reduction of capital
instruments in svb UK restoring it to
viability
it is my view Mr Speaker that in this
situation the system worked as we would
hope
in order to ensure the sale could
proceed the government is using its
powers under the Banking Act to provide
HSBC with an exemption to certain ring
fencing requirements this was crucial to
ensuring that a successful transaction
could be executed that the bank has the
liquidity it needs and that deposits and
public funds are protected
the outcome will provide security for
some of the UK's most Innovative fast
growing firms
the UK's Tech and Life Sciences sectors
are World leading hundreds of thousands
of people are employed in them and they
make a very substantial contribution to
the economy as a whole
my friends the Prime Minister and
Chancellor have been clear throughout we
will look after our high-tech sectors
and that is what we have done
the bank of England has confirmed that
as a result of the Swift decisive action
we have taken depositors will be able to
access their accounts it's worth
reiterating that as the governor has
said The Wider UK banking system remains
safe sound and well capitalized
Mr DW speaker in concluding I would like
to place on record my sincere thanks to
my fellow ministers across Whitehall to
officials at the treasury and Regulators
who work tirelessly through the weekend
to grip this situation to deliver this
solution and to prevent real Jeopardy to
hundreds of the UK's most Innovative
companies shuttlements
thank you Mr Speaker I thank the
minister for giving me an advanced site
of his statement today label welcomes
the announcement made by HSBC that it
will be buying the UK arm of Silicon
Valley Bank or svb UK in a rescue deal
as the shadow Chancellor said over the
weekend the UK life sciences and Tech
sector play an indispensable role in
driving growth and Innovation across the
economy
now that those who bank with svb UK have
some certainty the government should
examine how we got here in the first
place for example when SBB UK was
granted a separate banking license last
year what assessment did the treasury
and Bank of England made of the
significant liquidity risks arising from
its deposit base being a small number of
high-value corporate deposits the
effects of the collapse of svb are still
being felt across the UK market and the
minister said in a statement that hsbc's
purchase of svb has supported confidence
in the UK Financial system but what
assessment has he made of the fact that
London's ftse 100 was down today while
the UK bank index fell by almost 5 this
morning and by more than 10 percent over
the weekend what will the disruptions in
the banking sector mean for confidence
and The Wider economy and the ability of
high growth companies to access the
credit that they need to thrive
the minister also said that disruption
in the tech sector has been forestalled
but what reassurance can the minister
provide today that under hsbc's
ownership the bank will continue to be
able to support early stage Tech and
Life Sciences businesses in the UK
and the minister also said HSBC has been
given an exemption to certain ring fence
requirements could I ask the minister
will this be a permanent exemption
perhaps the most important question I'm
sure the minister will agree with me is
how can we avoid this happening again
would inflation at record levels the
bank of England has had to take steps to
tackling Rising prices that ministers
must make an assessment of the risks
that sharp changes to UK interest rates
might pose to our financial system it's
time for the government to launch in
systemic review of the risk that sharp
New Rising interest rates posed to the
UK financial sector and I hope the
chancellor will return to the house
having made that assessment finally the
events of this weekend further underline
the importance of ensuring that UK
startups have access to the patient
Capital they need to grow as proposed by
the labor party startup review
I hope the minister will return to the
house soon to update on both the broader
assessment of the risks to the financial
sector arising from sharply increasing
rates and with a plan to address the
longer term problems holding back growth
and the provision of patient Capital to
our growing businesses
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank the
honorable member for hamsters and
Kilburn I think concealed within that
was a grudging support uh and uh I'm
sure the honorable The Honorable lady
would like to add add her voice to so to
so many in the sector uh who have
welcomed this today providing the
importance uh the important confidence
and stability that is need she raised
the uh point about the fact that svb UK
has a separate banking license it's
precisely because of that mechanism that
our regulators and the treasury have
been able to take the action that we've
taken uh over the weekend I think the
honorable lady understands the
disruption uh and volatility in the
sector but she should also be reassured
that the bank of England Governor has
confirmed that this is not indicative of
systemic risk I can confirm that the
ring fencing in order that the Silicon
Valley Bank we're now within HSBC is
able to provide the broad range of
services that our life sciences and Tech
sector value so much that the exemption
from The Ring fencing requirements will
be permanent in terms of a question
about a systemic review of course uh
always these are opportunities for us to
learn and look again but as I said in my
opening remarks the system has worked Mr
Speaker as it was intended finally with
the greatest respect this side of the
house needs no lessons on patient
Capital we are unlocking uh capital for
our important Tech and Life Sciences
only last week my honorable friend the
men the minister for pensions brought to
this house the regulations that will
remove the charge cap and allow our
Pension funds to invest in some of the
fastest growing sectors of our economy
committee Harriet Baldwin thank you very
much Mr Speaker and uh can I put on
record my gratitude to the minister to
his colleagues to his officials to
people at the bank and to the city in
general who obviously worked flat out
all weekend to deliver what turns out to
be I think the best possible outcome in
these very difficult circumstances and
uh can I uh ask the minister in terms of
the importance of this sector to the UK
economy
um did he and the bank treat this
situation any differently because of the
sector in which it was operating or
would they have tried for the same sort
of a resolution and solution for a bank
in any sector secondly uh was he
concerned as I was to read reports that
actually investors in these businesses
were requiring the uh back the the funds
that their firms that they were funding
to put money into Bank as a condition
for investing in them does does that uh
concern him in any way and finally given
that in the US other banks have also
collapsed some other small Banks
including uh one that specialized in
crypto does he think that in any way
crypto is contributing to financial
instability
well I thank the uh The Honorable lady
my predecessor and chairman of the
select committee uh both for her support
and for her comments
um the degree of concentration of a
particular sector is unusual it was an
unusual feature the business model of
Silicon Valley Bank in the UK was
different uh to that from the US partly
because of the tight regulations that we
have here and for that reason I've not
seen any evidence to believe that crypto
crypto assets banking of crypto asset
companies uh was something that
contributed rather than saw the impact
once the FED had taken its action we saw
the impact of the bank here and that is
why it was right for the bank to act to
give us the space to protect that bank
and to achieve the outcome that we did
and that we have announced this morning
SMP spokes versus Stuart Jose De Mr
Speaker one of the key lessons of the
2008-9 financial crash it was that
conduct of business issues and liquidity
issues could vary very quickly morph
into systemic risk contagion across a
variety of transmission channels so I
very much welcome the Speedy way in
which svb UK was resolved over the
weekend
however
their business model and they're not
alone involved the bank holding a large
number of very low interest bearing
bonds at a time of rising bond yields
they were required to sell those at a
loss which exacerbated the liquidity
problems they have so would it not be
prudent now
to ensure our regulators
have another look at the UK Banks to
sure to ensure comparable low interest
bearing assets are stringently priced
marked to Market to make sure that the
capital requirements the tier one
capital is just that and it's of
sufficient quantity and quality to
ensure any liquidity problem does not
morph into an insolventy insolvency and
systemic risk problems
thank you very much I thank the member
for Dundee East for his recognition
about the speed and decisiveness uh with
which uh the whole government has come
together uh worked together and acted to
deliver this outcome that that that's
kind of him and appreciated uh there was
a question as well
um and and if I may we should not
conflate some of what we read about the
balance sheet in the US with the
regulated balance sheet in the UK this
was a separately regulated balance sheet
and again uh the business model in the
in the UK and the backing and the
interest bonds the bonds and collateral
that was being held I'm not aware that
the forced sale of that and losses on
that was a contributory Factor uh the
reality is that we saw a withdrawal of
deposits and it was that with the fact
that the bank had the ability because of
the relative typically ring fence
balance sheet that it had to protect the
bank and take the action we needed had
the bank not done so then we could have
been in a very different situation so we
were right to act as we did so the
science committed right thank you very
much Mr Speaker can I strongly welcome
the decisive intervention that has been
described that has saved many UK Tech
businesses and jobs and would my
honorable friend take the opportunity to
consider how the responsiveness of UK
regulation that has been demonstrated uh
overnight combined with the uh the the
strength of the city of London and our
Tech sector provides an opportunity to
attract more businesses to do their
financing within the UK and not need to
go overseas to get the financing that
they're required to start up and grow
my ride on a friend who does such good
work for the Science and Technology
committee uh Community through his
committee uh is absolutely right what uh
the the technology and Life Sciences
want uh our government to be joined up
to be decisive uh to remove unnecessary
regulations while still operating in a
high quality uh regulated environment uh
we have the opportunity Mr Speaker to
now go a lot for a lot further forward
to deliver the Edinburgh reforms to
combine our aspirations to be a science
superpower with the Ferocious financing
strengths that we have here in the
United Kingdom Angela yeah Mr Speaker I
commend the quick an effective action
but um the um collapse of SVP Bank in
America was partially due to the
liquidity issues but also there's an
issue of the changes that were made to
the Threshold at which banks are
considered systemically risky which went
from 50 billion dollars up to
250 billion dollars
um that meant that there was an issue
with svb that it could continue in
America without having the very focused
uh regulation which might have spotted
this problem earlier does the minister
think that the Edinburgh reforms offer
any similar risks and will he say a
little bit about the exemption from ring
fencing which he announced today for
HSBC and whether he's content that that
doesn't offer any risks either here
thank you Mr Speaker
I must be very careful Mr Speaker at not
to comment uh on the matters as it
relates to the United States this was a
separate Bank it was regulated here and
it's as a result of the regulation uh
and the fact we've taken back control of
our financial regulatory rule book that
we were able to act so decisively so
forgive The Honorable lady if I don't
talk about uh matters in the United
States in respective of ring fencing uh
it was the view of the bank of England
and the tertiary in the circumstances
and to protect public funds that to
provide a permanent exemption for what
is a very small part of a much larger
HSBC I think less than one percent of
its Pro former clients on a large basis
uh will be the former clients of the
Silicon Valley Bank that that was an
appropriate decision to make I don't
think it puts inappropriate levels of
risk in the system and by streamlining
the rule book by bringing back control
and dispensing that to UK Regulators
under the accountability to Parliament
and The Honorable lady will know that
through her membership of the select
committee I think we can have better
regulation and deliver better outcomes
for the sector
thank you Mr Speaker
um congratulations to my honorable
friend and to all who were involved in
this rescue it was absolutely
vital that we urgently acted to protect
the fear and the risk of contagion that
was very apparent over the weekend but
could my honorable friend comment on
whether the fact that SBB UK was a
separately ring fenced bank and that
ring fencing is a UK specific regulation
does he feel that that brought to bear
any protection for SBB UK he will recall
only too well as I do that Lehman's
sucked Capital out of the UK when they
were in Dire Straits that to a large
extent caused that ultimate contagion is
ring fencing going to continue to
protect UK banking sector as we go
forward and even through the Edinburgh
reforms
ah my uh my right armor was Ben's friend
speaks with great Authority on these
matters I can give her that Assurance uh
this was constituted as a subsidiary in
the UK it had its own separate balance
sheet it was regulated as such and it
was because of that fact that the bank
was able to make the decisive
intervention that it did whilst there
were assets within that subsidiary uh
that we were ultimately able to restore
viability by successfully finding over
the weekend a bank to step in and buy a
very large Bank Europe's largest bank to
put its balance sheet behind this entity
Mr Deputy speaker and whilst we're all
full of admiration particularly for all
of those of our officials who work
through the weekend to make this happen
I'm afraid I find the statement
a bit long on self-congratulation and a
bit short on explanation what questions
has the minister asked as to why this
happened why were all these companies
banking with this particular Bank what
cultural aspects were there to this case
what what do we need to uncover that
will be important for the sustainability
of both Banking and technological firms
in the future
uh Mr Speaker Deputy speaker it's not
uncommon uh for banks to have a
particular specialism uh the members
opposite have worked to help bring
forward regulations that will help us
have more credit unions which tend to
have a geographic concentration there
are agricultural Banks and there are
other wholesale Banks so it's not of
itself an unusual feature
um in this case we were able to take
action precisely because of the UK
regulatory structures the interventions
that we make we'll learn any lessons
going forward but this is a government
that is on the side of technology
companies and life sciences and has been
proud to deliver this outcome this
important certainty and remove the
Jeopardy that they otherwise faced at
open of business this morning
estimate had the bank of England made of
the health of SBB before the events of
the weekend
that that it it wouldn't it wouldn't be
right for me to um to to answer on
behalf of the bank of England we have uh
I I forgive um The Honorable gentleman
but we have an independent uh regulator
who looks at these matters the treasury
select committee regularly takes
evidence from the bank of England and
I'm sure we'll do so in the future
Sammy Wilson
Mr W speaker I'm sure that many firms
across the United Kingdom will welcome
and be breathing a style of relief at
the decision which has been made over
the weekend however
this was done in haste
I asked the minister
what kind of due diligence was done by
each SPC when arranging this takeover
and is he sure that we are not walking
into the similar situation which he had
with Lloyds and each boss in 2008 were a
quick decision led to a domino effect in
the banking system resulting in bailouts
by the taxpayer
this is Deputy speaker um I I can't
speak for the due diligence that was
done for HSBC they they must uh they've
got themselves comfortable with that uh
we should also understand the relative
scale of HSBC HSBC is an extraordinarily
well-regulated it's a global and diverse
Bank my understanding is that if you add
all of the clients the important clients
that we had in the front of our mind as
we sought to act over the weekend and we
make no apologies if I may for acting in
haste haste was the absolute required
procedure uh in this particular case but
if you took the entirety of the clients
of Silicon Valley Bank UK that will be
less than one percent of the overall
client base of HSBC and with respect I
don't think that was the case in the
examples that The Honorable member
referred to
Anthony Brown okay thank you Mr Deputy
speaker the the size of a relief across
South Cambridgeshire this morning was so
loud they were almost deafening dozens
of my technology companies that have
been contact with me over the weekend I
thought they're going to be wiped out
this morning but uh and it can Now
operate as normal because of the
decisive action by the government and I
very much congratulate uh the minister
and the uh the bank of England and the
treasury for its action but I've also
had questions about whether this is a
sign that all the reforms the financial
system in the wake of the global
financial crisis have failed or are
failing and uh but can the uh my right
normal front Minister uh does he agree
with me that actually this isn't a sign
the reforms failing it's a sign of them
actually working without these reforms
he wouldn't be able to do the rescue in
this way and secondly the reforms that
are coming through the edema reforms can
he confirm they won't make future
collapses more likely or future rescues
more difficult
uh what my friend the member for South
Cambridge you know it's a great deal
about the sector uh it is due to past
reforms uh that we've been we're able to
take the decisive action Parliament uh
has given in extremists and with the
agreement of the bank of England the pra
the FCA and the treasury uh sweeping
powers to enable this sort of
transaction to happen at Great pace and
let me be clear Mr Deputy speaker uh it
is the shareholders and the creditors of
the bank not the depositors or the
taxpayer has lost and in the system that
we have that is the right outcome uh and
I'm very pleased that we were able to
achieve that outcome of course it is the
case that the Edinburgh reforms which
are designed to make this country uh
have the ability to continue to grow and
be internationally competitive so with
other markets whilst adhering to the
highest quality regulatory standards and
with the UK at the absolute Cornerstone
of organizations like the financial
stabilities board will not put any more
Jeopardy into the financial system in
fact having good healthy businesses that
grow in a profitable is the best way to
avoid Jeopardy
it's a deputy speaker fast Pension funds
and ldis now the collapse of svb UK
isn't it time for a systematic review of
the risks that Sharpie Rising interest
rates pose to the UK financial sector
um
the greatest respect to the honorable
lady um the the issue here
was a subsidiary of a U.S Bank I'm not
going to be commenting on U.S policy on
interest rates or anything else for that
matter from this dispatch box the
important fact is that we were able to
restore this bank to viability to over
the course of a very small number of
hours and days to find a successful
buyer and we did that because of the
strength of the UK regulatory system and
because of the conviction of this prime
minister and this Chancellor that this
is an absolutely critical sector and one
of the ways that we continue to grow the
UK economy
Danny Krueger indeed Mr Speaker and can
I also pay tribute to the exemplary
orchestration of all the different
stakeholders and decision makers that
the minister uh LED over the weekend I
think it's helpful to distinguish
between the decisions taken by the
American government and by ours in
respect to this Bank you know the
American taxpayer is guaranteeing the
deposits of spp account holders there in
our case then other Bankers bought them
and the taxpayer is safe and I pay
tribute to the government for that I
appreciate if you can't comment on
American policy but just in the
hypothetical instance of another bank in
the UK failing or another sector getting
into trouble can you give an indication
of his thinking about whether the
taxpayer would ever need to be to step
in and will he guarantee that in fact
that won't happen
it's Deputy speaker
um I'm not gonna I'm not gonna offer the
honor of my honorable friend for devises
uh that guarantee that wouldn't be
prudent and the right thing to do but
what I can guarantee is that this
government will do everything possible
to reconcile the needs of protecting
customers of protecting Financial
stability and or protecting the taxpayer
and it is of great uh note that we're
able to do that in this transaction and
all of our energies if it were ever to
unfortunately recur would be devoted to
precisely the same ends
Mr Deputy speaker I very much welcome uh
the purchase of Silicon Valley Bank UK
by HSBC this morning not least because
I'm a former employee of a company that
had exposure to the bank on both sides
of the Atlantic and whose CEO was one of
the signatories to the letter sent to
the chancellor on Saturday and
statements made by the uh Bank on the UK
bank on Thursday and Friday uh if
depositors had relied on the assertions
made in those statements and if the
purchase hadn't gone through this
morning those depositors would have
incurred losses now can the minister
confirm does that constitute a breach of
the regulations and if it does will
there be any sanctions on the on people
identified as having committed those
breaches
um thank you Mr Speaker I'm delighted
that uh The Honorable member for
Richmond's Park constituents uh do
benefit from the certainty it was a
terrible weekend uh for everybody who
was a depositor or who was in some way
dependent uh on SBB UK and that's why it
was so important that we not just
achieve this outcome that the regulatory
structure and laws laid down by
Parliament allowed us to but that we're
able to act decisively and I welcome the
fact uh that another Great British Bank
HSBC has stepped in uh and I wish them
well and all of the employees
in terms of particular things that were
said it would be inappropriate for me to
comment uh but fortunately we are in the
position uh that every depositor has
been made whole and then therefore that
issue does not arise
can I massively congratulate my
honorable friend and his Majesty's
government on this news having spent
three years of my own life posting the
post-crash bank recovery and resolution
Frameworks through Europe I can
absolutely confirm that the fact that
there are now powers in so many
countries to be able to rapidly resolve
failing Banks without needing taxpayers
money is to a very large part due to the
outstanding Global Leadership of the
post-crash conservative UK government
and the actions of the now governor of
the bank of England at this time so can
he confirm that going forward the
government will ensure that our
financial services Regulators not only
work to reduce systemic risk but also
back our financial services sector in
their efforts to invest in our country
and help our economy grow
I can absolutely give my honorable
friend for chelms with that assurance
and in doing so let me also pay tribute
to her work as a member of the European
Parliament between 2009 and 2017 when
she led on banking reform Stephen
kinnick thank you very much Mr Deputy
speaker the the minister has talked
about the fact that svb UK was a
subsidiary of the American Bank but the
fact is that the banking license here in
this country was a separate banking
license given to svb UK so could I just
push him on this issue of the risk
assessment around liquidity what risk
assessment when that banking license was
given what risk assessment was conducted
particularly given the concentration of
a small number of corporates in terms of
the deposits to svb UK
uh that that is uh with respect Mr
Debbie speak for the whole point it was
a subsidiary it did have a separate
banking license here it did it did
participate in the regulator's stress
tests here
um there is risk in any Financial system
uh and and what this house is focused on
and what our diligent Regulators are
focused on is achieving the right
balance of that risk uh There Will from
time to time as there were with the
failure of the bank in the U.S uh there
will be some factors uh that can lead to
challenges in any risk-based system
notwithstanding good work by The
Regulators and the stress tests having
been applied would you pull up
speaker kind of draw The house's
attention to my historical entries in my
register of interests as an advisor to a
technology Venture fund and as a board
member of a number of portfolio
companies many of which will have had
financing arrangements with Silicon
Valley Bank HSBC and other financial
institutions uh Mr Speaker on behalf of
the technology businesses in
bedfordshire can I add my thanks to the
minister and his team for their Swift
response over the weekend but he will be
aware of General concerns about the
global liquidity for the technology
sector and I'd be interested about his
assessment about how the svb experience
at home and abroad May exacerbate that
and the resilience of the UK Tech sector
and although Mr W speaker HSBC is a
great bank and indeed I am a customer of
HSBC Silicon Valley Banks succeeded over
many years precisely because it was so
closely attenuated to the needs of early
state agent growth stage businesses so
will my honorable friend consider what
steps he can take to encourage the
emergence of new Challenger Banks to
repeat the successes and avoid the
failures of svb in the UK
I think my uh my friend meant for The
Honorable member for North East uh
bedfordshire
um as he knows uh the government is
seeking to support Challenger Banks to
make sure that we have a vibrant and
competitive sector uh that includes
looking at issues like the level of M
rail making sure that we have
proportionate uh banking regulation that
is relevant to the risk involved he
makes important points about the the
culture and capabilities of svb UK which
is why it is so important that we had to
very swiftly find them a home I have
spoken today to the chief executive of
HSBC as well as the former chief
executive of SV svb UK they are both
enormously excited about the future they
see this as a platform for Mutual growth
for taking our brilliant life sciences
and Technology businesses International
or to a new scale and this government
will not rest until so we have mobilized
Capital to turn us into that science
superpower
Mr Deputy speaker the system worked the
minister says and certainly it was a
huge relief that the estimated 50
percent of the UK Tech sector which
banked with ukb UK with svb UK so uh
could today play its suppliers and its
staff but surely that highlights the
lack of diversity of the capital
available to the UK Tech sector and our
dependence on the US so in Silicon
Valley banks in the last two years their
deposits went up by three times but
their exposure to treasuries and
therefore to interest rate Rises went up
nine-fold is the minister seriously
saying that no one this side of the
Atlantic should have noticed that and it
had no impact on what happened yeah The
Honorable member for Newcastle talks
about dependence on the US if that's her
concern then she should welcome this
deal heartedly because we've taken a
former subsidiary of a U.S business
that's now part of a thriving and
successful UK business
[Music]
thank you uh Mr Deputy speaker draw
attention to my entry in the register uh
Bravo to the minister and Bravo in
particular to The Resolution Team at the
bank of England who've been honing their
skills for many years and finally got
the chance to put them into uh use but
further to the question from my um
constituency neighbor The Honorable for
devises does the minister understand the
relief uh felt by many that the taxpayer
was once again was not asked to once
again step in and effectively
nationalize private sector losses and
does he agree that for a capitalist
economy to function even in the most
painful of circumstances it has to be
allowed to do what it does best which is
to recycle distressed assets
well I think my uh my honorable friend
member for the ride on room for North
the Northwest Hampshire
um look he's quite right when he talks
about risk and the proficiency of
capital systems of recycling Capital to
productive uses uh it is also an
enormous focus of this government and
it's why our number one priority was to
seek to make a private sector transfer
of the bank in this case if we could to
protect the taxpayer whilst also
protecting customers and the solvency of
the financial system I'm glad we're able
to achieve this output and the reason
that we will continue to do so is by
having fit for purpose regulations in
this space I'm Kaiser thank you Mr
Deputy speaker does the minister agree
that the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
highlights the dangers associated with
deregulation within the banking sector
something that the UK government has
continually toted it's one of the
benefits of brexit
here here yeah no I don't accept that
for one minute Mr Deputy speaker because
we're only just getting we're only just
bringing forward uh the deregulation the
financial services and Market spill is
not even on the statute book and the
pertinent regulation is precisely that
affected this situation is precisely the
same regulations that we've inherited
from Brussels
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's at
times when we act in haste where we need
to think about the long-term
consequences
um of the regulatory actions taken and I
join others in the house in commending
the treasury and The Wider government
the bank of England in relation to ring
fencing in particular the minister said
that HSBC has been given a waiver on
certain ring fencing rules I say this is
somebody who before I got to this house
worked at HSBC in detail on ring fencing
and many other things so would the
minister explain more details in
relation to that waiver and more
importantly whether that waiver on ring
fencing will apply more widely to other
banks caught by ring fencing regulations
as well
I think you remember the honorable
member for Hitchin and Harper doing for
his question uh the government is as he
well knows uh undertaking a review of
ring fencing there's a an expression of
a call for evidence expressions of
Interest into how we could reform that
following the work done by Sir Keith
skioch as to how we mesh the ring
fencing Arrangements put in place back
in 2008 uh with the more modern
resolution uh Arrangements uh of course
we'll learn what lessons we can from
here from from this but as I said at the
beginning Mr Deputy speaker in this case
we've been able to achieve an outcome
that has protected customers uh
protected protected the taxpayer and
protected the financial system
I I too had many representations over
the weekend from early stage tech
companies in and around Cambridge and
they will be much relieved by the news
today but to Echo the point made by the
on the northeast bedfordshire the reason
they banked with SBB was that close
understanding of their particular needs
so what guarantee can we have that HSBC
will be able to replicate that
what
the how they run how they run this Bank
going forward is a matter for HSBC uh
however it's a prodigiously successful
Global institution uh it's bought this
on the back of a desire to grow and to
support sectors that it sees that this
government is firmly on the side of we
see the aspiration we see the
opportunity now that we've taken back
control from Brussels and we're going to
make an enormous success out of our Tech
and Life Sciences sector we are on their
side
images
Mr Deputy speaker can I welcome my
honorable friends statement and
congratulate him on all those who've
worked to resolve this matter so quickly
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank will
have left its customers worried about
managing their cash flows and it's
obviously cash flow problems which cause
the majority of businesses to fail
in his statement he mentioned that
customers would continue to have access
to their deposits can you just comment
is that seamless is that going to
continue right away so the business
continuity is safeguarded
uh I think you'll remember for Harrogate
and Ezra and again to pay tribute to the
hard-working officials from treasury
regulators and my colleagues across
government who pull together uh rapidly
to deliver this uh solution it is the
case and there may be uh teething
teething issues as as the uh integration
takes place but it is the case having
spoken to uh both HSBC and to the
management of svb UK that they are open
for business today they are serving
their clients and that is the outcome
all along that the Prime Minister and
Chancellor were absolutely right that we
sought in time for this morning's
opening of business there's your Cooper
a deputy speaker I'd like to press the
minister on his answer to my honorable
honorable friend from Richmond Park at
least two companies in my constituency
were almost affected and I'm grateful to
the economic secretary for acknowledge
acknowledging my urgent letters over the
weekend but one of these companies
instant Albans moved 200 000 pounds from
their U.S account to their UK account in
part based on the statements made about
svb being an independent entity
regulated in the UK statements that bank
made to try and give them reassurance
that it wouldn't be affected it then did
become affected so could I ask the
minister can he clarify whether svb
would or should have known that this
statement was either incorrect or
misleading if he's not prepared to
comment on this particular example will
he commit to setting up a process to
look into this issue and does he believe
there should be consequences for banks
in future that make these incorrect or
misleading statements that put companies
at risk
well as I said to um her her neighbor uh
The Honorable for rip for Richmond Park
um I don't think it's appropriate with
respect that I uh make comments from the
dispatch Box about the veracity or
otherwise of statements of an individual
I hope she will respect that it is of
course right that anyone in a position
of leadership in business takes
responsibility and acts in good faith uh
the important point for her constituents
although she although there may well be
lessons to be learned in time is that
her constituents and their companies are
able to operate have access to their
deposits and continue to do their work
of growing really important sectors of
the economy I hope the whole house can
welcome that Mr Graham Mr Deputy speaker
congratulations to the chancellor
Minister and all involved in resolving
this problem which tech companies in
Gloucester and Gloucester will greatly
appreciate does the minister agree that
this shows the importance of having
Europe's largest bank the Hong Kong and
Shanghai banking corporation regular
related and headquartered here in London
that it also shows this government will
always support business and lastly since
the chancellor extended startup loans in
September can I order a friend confirm
that effectively this government has
helped create and sustain 33 000 new
businesses
but my right honorable friend for
Gloucester Gloucester here is absolutely
right and what this has demonstrated is
that we are on the side of business we
mean it when we say that we want to make
the UK the best place to start to grow
and to run a business instead it also
add to list a business because he's
quite right that HSBC is an enormously
successful Global business headquartered
in the UK and proudly listed on the UK
Stock Exchange
thank you very much Mr WC well in the
light of recent events and the risk of
contagion can the minister naturally
spell out exactly what actions he's
taking to ensure that we do not see a
contraction in the availability of
credit to these specialist fast-growing
companies and what more will he do to
facilitate access to appropriate credit
to help our groundbreaking Tech
Industries to develop
it's a core focus of this side of the
house to make sure that our scaling up
businesses get not access not just to
credit uh but also to Capital uh at
every level through their life that's
why uh the Prime Minister has made that
a core priority it's why we're bringing
forward many of our reforms which will
open up Capital markets to Growing
businesses and it's why we will continue
to look at reforming
packets of Trapped Capital whether that
be an insurers through the reform of
solvency too or whether looking again at
the pension arrangements to make sure
that Savers and potential pensioners in
the future can benefit from the
wonderful opportunities from the
emerging businesses in the tech and Life
Sciences sector
Matt Warman almost Deputy speaker had
SBB UK not been uh bought then it would
have had a huge impact on the jobs out
that our most high-tech in our economy
and indeed on the jobs of the future so
I pay tribute to the minister and the
whole government and Bank of England for
the work they did over the weekend and
thank him for engaging with me but does
he agree with me that because of that
outsize impact that the failure of svb
might have had it is all the more
important that the government looks at
what it was that made SBB so appealing
to these vital jobs how we do more of it
where it is right and how we do less of
it if it is dangerous
I completely agree with my honorable
friend he knows a great deal about this
subject it reflects his own background
and he's absolutely right
can I thank the the minister foreign
and the speed by which government has
acted quickly is to be commanded and it
is indeed good news I say welcome very
much the purchase of the svb by etsbc
which looks said to protect the UK
investors and the startups alike what
further assurances can the minister give
this house that the 3500 British
customers receive in terms of the
long-term plan and how long is the
government the commitment to study the
ship
well this government is always committed
to study the ship it's why we take a
prudent approach to running the economy
uh it's why the prime minister's
priorities are to reduce inflation uh to
pay down debt and to grow and to grow
requires the capital which is why we
have a long-term commitment to good
regulation which will minimize the
prospects of events like this happening
again but it's also why and you can see
the expertise on this side of the house
that we are so focused on making sure
that we have the right ecosystem to
allow our brilliant entrepreneurs our
scientists our innovators to have the
fertile capital and which to grow to
their potential final question Louis
French thank you thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and for transparency I draw
members attention to my former career in
the city as per my register of interests
and I welcome the Swift and decisive
action by his Majesty's government in
solving um this issue but also reducing
the contagion risk to The Wider economy
that could have in place however can my
honorable friend ensure sufficient
regulatory strength work is taking place
to stress test both the liquidity of UK
Banks and also the government bull
markets given the clear risk highlighted
in this case but also in the leverage in
the recent ldi cases yeah
yeah so I can give that I can give the
house as well as my honorable friend for
old Bexley and Sid cup that commitment
we will learn uh lessons if there are
lessons that need to be learned but we
should not look past the fact that Mr
Deputy speaker uh today we have
protected customers we have protected uh
the taxpayer we've protected the
security of the financial system that is
so important to our businesses many many
people will go home from work today much
more confident with the Jeopardy of the
weekend having removed as a result of
the decisive action that this government
has taken
I'd like to thank the minister for his
statement today and for responding to
questions for over three quarters of an
hour thank you
just pause for the choreography
I'll do it with a 12.
the clerk will now proceed to read the
orders of the day
illegal migration